we predicted this would happen but now
it's time to really get our hands sort
of dirty because the Treasury led by
Trump flunky Stephen minuchin is
officially refusing to turn over Donald
Trump's tax returns which were requested
legally by congressman Richard Neal on
the basis of a law from the 1920s in his
role as chairman of the House Ways and
Means Committee the reason why minuchin
is refusing to turn over Trump's tax
returns is exactly the reason that we
predicted which is that the request from
Committee Chairman Richard Neal quote
lacks a legitimate legislative purpose
which minuchin claims is required by the
Supreme Court and over to in order to
turn over tax returns unfortunately it
doesn't appear that that's actually the
case so I'm gonna explain this all to
you piece by piece and what you have to
remember is that Steven minuchin was
advised by Trump's Justice Department in
terms of how to not provide these tax
returns the Trump Justice Department is
led of course by none other than
Attorney General William bar a
professional at covering up the misdeeds
of presidents of the United States so
this is a loss if you were expecting
that today we would get Donald Trump's
tax returns but it's completely expected
and it's now going to set off a legal
battle that could actually be positive
in a way in the sense that it's going to
put Donald Trump's tax returns and more
importantly the fact that we haven't
seen them back in the news which
strategically is good for Democrats
because most Americans want to see
Donald Trump's taxes so that's the
strategy let's first go through the
legality of this there's a law that's
very clear
okay the law dates back to the 1920s I
think it's 24 but I'm going from memory
and the law says that if you're a member
of the House and Senate House or Senate
who is on a tax writing committee and
there are a number of committees that
have tax writing privileges you were
able to legally request the tax returns
of any taxpayer and that the IRS quote
shall furnish them period there are no
caveats there there are no ifs ands and
buts
you can request them if you're on one of
those committees and the IRS shall
furnish them doesn't allow for getting
help from the Justice Department to try
to block the request something which a
president can try but most citizens
would not be able to try to get the
Justice Department to help them block
the release of their tax returns but the
one question about all of this was is
there any precedent which says that if
you want to request a tax return from an
individual taxpayer on this basis using
this law that you need to justify a
legislative purpose for the request if
there is Richard Neil says the committee
is looking into whether mandatory IRS
audits of sitting presidents are good
policies so he's come up with a reason a
justification a legislative
justification if indeed one is needed
now the truth is that claiming you need
a reason is pretty dubious and the
reason that we know that's the case is
by looking at the law if you look at 26
US Code subsection 6103 doesn't say
anything about a legislative purpose it
says just quote upon written request
from the chairman of the Committee on
house on ways and means of the House of
Representatives the chairman of the
Committee on Finance of the Senate or
the chairman of the Joint Committee on
taxation the secretary of the Treasury
that means shall furnish such committee
with any return or return information
specified in such request except that
any return or return information which
can be associated with or otherwise
identify directly or indirectly a
particular taxpayer shall be furnished
to such committee only when sitting in
closed executive session unless such
taxpayer otherwise consents in writing
to such disclosure so what it says is
that it has to be submitted privately
right in executive session unless the
taxpayer says it's okay for it to be
made more widely available it says
nothing about legislative purpose
minuchin has come up with a viable
explanation but it's nowhere in the law
it says that
secretary of the treasury shall furnish
not secretary of the Treasury will
analyze whether they believe there is a
legislative purpose and evaluate whether
in their opinion it is a legitimate
legislative purpose this is arguably
another act of obstruction if Trump
directed the Justice Department to help
the Treasury not follow the law
it is another instance and there are
already 14 others which we'll talk about
later it is another instance of
obstructing the process of Justice it's
another checkbox so to speak in the list
of things Nixon resigned over which
Donald Trump has also done so that's the
legal side of it
then there's the strategy piece seeing
Trump's tax returns is very popular with
Americans it goes beyond just Democrats
so simply keeping this in the news is
probably a good strategy particularly as
a reminder as 2020 sort of heats up that
Donald Trump still hasn't released his
taxes and is actively using his Justice
Department and the Treasury to keep
those tax returns secrets so even if
this fails to get Trump's tax returns
over to the House Ways and Means
Committee which it very well may because
this is an administration that just
ignores subpoenas ignores requests and
they don't seem to be suffering any
consequences for that even if it doesn't
achieve that it still is likely a useful
thing for Democrats in 2020 just as a
reminder that we've still not seen those
tax returns and Donald Trump is going
even more out of his way than he has at
any previous point to prevent those tax
returns from going public last caveat if
you think that the tax returns if we saw
them would expose criminality by Trump I
don't think so I think the most likely
scenario is the taxes would expose the
Donald Trump is not nearly as wealthy as
he claims to be and maybe some of this
manipulation of property values higher
when it's advantageous and lower when
it's advantageous but I don't think
you're gonna get the bombshell
criminality that summer are sort of
hoping for if you disagree though let me
know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
if you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video